my name is Freddy Martinez and I'm a
privacy and technology advocate the
stairs are a trademark name for us
there's a corporation called Harris
corporation they sell this technology
that they call stingrays so it's kind of
used as a colloquial you know general
term for cellphone site simulators about
two years ago I found out that this
technology existed and I knew enough
about telephones to know that if you're
running one of these big cell phone
towers you can gather a lot of
information the phone numbers the number
of text messages locations times all
kinds of you know what people call
metadata isn't just you know general
information it's actually quite
revealing information so I finally won
my first class with Chicago police
I waited one month or in acknowledgment
I'm I didn't get anything I waited two
months I waited three months at about
four months I still hadn't gotten a
confirmation of it they received my
request I think it was about five months
in that we really I joined in with a
attorney who specializes in FOIA and we
filed a lawsuit against this department
they're just exploiting a vulnerability
in something that everyone uses every
day they're probably more information I
our cell phone then there is maybe even
on your work computer or on your laptop
so these are really like portals into
our everyday lives after we filed a
lawsuit against Chicago police we found
that stingrays were bought with what are
called 1505 funds they're essentially
our Kotik seizure funds the first
lawsuit was for purchase orders for
sting rings the second lawsuit was we
wanted to find out how this information
with being conveyed to judges whether
the privacy issues were being addressed
how the technology was being described
in obtaining search warrants it seems
that they're not obtaining search
warrants
what worries me the most is yeah it's
it's the lack of ability to get actual
public information from public products
what I found
with FOIA and I've only been doing it
for about a year and a half is that if
you really do want to get information
you are gonna need to sue over it and
you need to really stay on it and follow
a ton of them and just keep going with
it because no one's going to give you
the information just because you ask for
it at least give it to me if it's useful
in any way